you know there are a few things Riot
Games loves more than a good storyline
and there are a few storylines better
than that of the underdog you know David
versus Goliath the misfits vs. SKT if
you will that's why this week we decide
to give you the top 10 underdog moments
in League of Legends
these are the one-off upset victories or
the Cinderella bracket runs that made us
want to stand up and cheer for the
little guy these are the underdog wins
or near wins that warmed our cold
shriveled eSports hearts so without
further ado guys let's get into it with
a top 10 underdog moments in league
before 2014 no one gave an international
wildcard team a second look the 10th
spot on our list belongs to a team that
blew up Group D at the 2014 World
Championship kaboom the first seed from
Europe Alliance were locked in a dead
heat with the second na seed in cloud 9
and the favored Koreans najin white
shield their match against kaboom was
more important than ever a win would put
c9 into a must-win situation against
najin to force a three-way tie breaker
what was expected to be Alliance
brushing aside the wild card turned into
kaboom surprising everyone with their
early aggression and forcing alliance
into uncharacteristically bad teamfights
like I wanna fight indeed from our gets
it up here but what we knif next
they're looking for more kills on this
one Tainos over the wall sap just misses
sniff could be the next one to go down
that's fine if webkinz over the wall and
kaboom goes the dynamite what the hell
was that bro there was the worst engage
I've ever ever seen Alliance was pushed
all the way back to their base but
kaboom never let up and overthrew the
kings of Europe
then I can't believe the diva
take the cable Reliance
[Applause]
c9 will go on to beat najin to eliminate
Europe's best hope for a world
championship in forming a bond with the
Brazilian wildcard that had proven the
world wrong since kaboom V Alliance that
one goes for them with one of the
biggest upset runs in na LCS playoff
history our number nine moment comes
from good game University in the
inaugural na LCS playoffs during the
regular season GG you played their role
of a middling team well with an 11 and
17 record going negative against each of
the top three teams and barely avoiding
the promotion tournament no one gave
this team of fresh faces much of a
chance against the 3rd seeded Dignitas
Judi fight getting evaporated right now
down to 300 health they tended with us
if again when they go for the Nexus JJ
Yogi's think the tops the playoff then
moved on to face the number 2 seated
curse the turrets are falling over the
champions are falling over good game
University are into the finals against
teams all of it once again at GG you won
the series 2-1 and found themselves in
the finals against the number one seeded
TSM TSM comes into this matches the top
seed in the playoffs and the hottest
team in the LCS TSM to no one's surprise
took a clinging Game one but GG you
exploded out of the gate in game 2
winning a perfect 27 minute game coming
in oh oh my gosh me going so hard in
this gun just to get out they may have a
good position on the box they dream and
just save you
so much the odwin goes and he says I
could get through no you can GG do sets
up a choke point on the backside of the
top of turret they do keep diving into
this one going down oh it's the
surrender coming in after two more back
and forth games GG you managed to do
what no one could have expected and took
TSM to a decisive Game five
although they didn't manage to overcome
the kings of Na in the end GG you proved
that your regular-season record doesn't
matter and that in the playoffs anything
is possible
from 12 to 2 to the championship game
taking 2nd place in the spring split a
quite a run they took GSM to all five
games forced to play their way into
Worlds 2017 the number 8 moment on our
list goes to fnatic the third European
seed found themselves in a group with
the top North American and Korean seeds
as well as one of the strongest
wild-card teams to ever attend Worlds
unfortunately for the Europeans the
first four days seemed to play out as
expected with fnatic losing their first
four games of the tournament to even
have a chance and making it out of
groups they needed to win their next two
games and hope for a tiebreaker scenario
nobody has ever qualified for
quarterfinals after starting the
tournament oh three and week one fnatic
did their part with their deliberate
team fighting to force a three-way tie
breaker
and fanatic they needed to win and they
done it the team would play immortals
with the winner taking on gigabyte
marines for the final spot in the
quarterfinals their teamwork proved too
much for immortals
to break world history there's the Nexus
goes down tomorrow to bring joy to the
world
came to play fnatic was one win away
from becoming the first team to make the
quarterfinals after going down oh and
four in a bloody back-and-forth game
fnatic superior macro play earned them
the win and a trip to the world's
quarterfinals
although they would soon fall 3-1 to
Royal never give up it was their
miraculous escape from the near death
sentence that is an O and for record
that earns them a spot on this list so
many expectations / fanatic no one in
this group stage format has come back
from an O 3 let alone in O 4 an
absolutely miraculous run a Cinderella
story for fanatic from challenger all
the way to world's the seventh spot on
our list belongs to the famous run from
origin in 2015 the team rolled their way
through EU Challenger only dropping a
single game and qualified for the EU LCS
summer split origin group they had what
it took to play in the LCS crushing
their way through the split never
falling lower than third winning we used
3rd spot at Worlds through the regional
qualifier all the way
pushed by rocket Oh literate unicorns of
love booked their tickets to Paris in a
group with kt rolster LGD and TSM no one
expected Origen to even make it out of
groups but once again Origen rose to the
challenge advancing out of the group to
the quarterfinals against Ella messes
flash wolves experience playing against
min the best of five and they are very
energetic throughout they are good at
adapting the coach understands the draft
how to adapt properly so I expect them
to do exactly the same in his matches
Origen proved they weren't just masters
of the best of one and took the series
3-1 to move on to the semi-finals
a VHF as
while their run was stopped as many are
at the hands of SKT Origen proved that a
team with the right chemistry can climb
to just about any height
[Applause]
our number six entry on this list comes
from the 2016 midseason Invitational off
the back of their second consecutive
domestic championship counter logic
gaming face down for daunting opponents
after going to and - in the first two
days CLG got a chance at a breakthrough
against SKT after being down for more
than 40 minutes
CLG managed to hold on and find an
opening scoring magnificent win after
SKT took their revenge on day for CLG
matched up against the undefeated royal
never give up the early game swung in
our Angie's favour but CLG held on a
game and at 37 minutes xmithie turned
the entire game on its head
[Music]
with the most unlikely victory after
taking out flash wolves in these
semi-finals CLG could not overcome faker
and SKT in the finals but with this run
they had proven that na was a serious
contender on the international stage
let's be honest here nearly everyone is
an underdog when facing down SKT
rounding out the top five is the little
EU team that could in Misfits coming all
the way from challenger the previous
season misfits finished second in the
summer split to secure the second EU
seed at Worlds they managed to squeak
out of groups with a three and three
record after winning a tiebreaker
against TSM like in a rush the Nexus
these are the wolves rookies these up
side with the Nexus open
that's fit push themself straight into
the quarterfinals now the European Dark
Horse had their toughest test the Korean
dynasty SK Telecom t1 it's very exciting
it would also be a massive upset of
anything other than the expected result
happens I mean it's SK Telecom t1 we're
used to seeing this team in the final
after losing the first game Misfits held
strong winning an impeccable game 2 on
the back of team coordination
ready
not his own choice peanut goes down
there's no it's might fight misfits are
gonna pick up baron less favor one was
25 minutes walk straight from the
factory from his package the nexus is
going to be open and misfits are going
to find the victory in game 2
dottie one in Game three all bets were
off with ignores fervor Leona pick in
the bot lane misfits had a plan and
managed to secure the first two kills of
the game immediately no flash forward
but the heel comes out they turned to
walf his bag feels like you get back
into the fight just a hundred so as
novio on Saba one more shot as well
quads the glitter lands
[Applause]
pull the trigger they managed to hold on
to their lead and take a 2-1 series lead
and they are going for hooting up
looking for the kills looking to secure
it looki to be the first team ever to
accomplish what no
eventually experienced one the day and
SKT managed to stave off the misfits
onslaught and capitalize on mistakes to
win Game four and five so much Petiot
credit over two misfits like what a
performance in this series so few people
thought they could do anything against
SKT game 1 was a complete stomp 25
minutes in favor of SKT and then they
pounds back for these off meta patriot
leona baguette Blitzcrank they went to
games on the road even in the slow games
here came four and five they were so
close to actually feeding SKT was
definite alaik him just purely in favor
of the korean team
misfits shocked the world in 2017 they
were one teamfight away from the biggest
upset league had ever seen from
challenger to almost champion killers
when you think of underdogs in League of
Legends you probably think of the
international wildcard spot at Worlds
and the fourth spot on our list goes to
the most iconic wild card run in league
history
[Applause]
Elvis knocks Luna came into world's 2015
with precisely zero expectations they
were even considered the best wild card
team at the tournament after a bloody
but decisive loss to the rocks tigers
everyone's expectations seemed to be
coming true when Albus Knox had other
plans
they beat CLG g2 and then CLG again one
more win and they would become the
first-ever wild card to make it out of
groups na next win like you said does
currently McWhorter finals berth reading
Rox gives them a shot at first place in
the group as well but it's unthinkable
for this team coming into the tournament
and Ulmus Knox did not disappoint in an
almost 70 minute bloodbath they kept the
tournament favorites against the ropes
and managed to become the most
successful wild card team in league of
legends history
try to take the brain the next to the
label
[Applause]
just took down the rock
[Applause]
just took down the rocks Tigers and I'm
challenging them for the number one spot
in Group A hey guys they're from Ralph
Carr and they have told you before being
underdog doesn't mean being a loser so
in our bronze medal moment from IEM
katowice 2015 the LPL's most unlikely
hero challenged korea's dominance on the
international stage the GE Tigers were
having an incredible split with a
perfect 10 and OH record and had a
combined game score of 20 and two world
elite only had a single series win to
their name and a game score of 8 and 22
but by edging out oMG and EDG at the IEM
Shenzhen qualifier w/e won a spot in
Katowice that's the really scary thing
about world wheat is that the language
barrier the roster changes they're still
trying to find their synergy and the
fact that they're dismantling top tier
teams in the LPL with kind of a lack of
synergy kind of speaks to the strength
of the players right now can you imagine
when they were finally firing on all
cylinders the Tigers blew through their
group knocking down cloud 9 and SK
gaming to qualify for the semi-finals
will delete took a tougher road after
losing to TSM they went on to knock out
gambit and the second Korean seed in CJ
entus and so the stage was set for the
semi-final the Tigers won Game one as
expected but in game 2 world elite held
on and after winning a scrappy dragon
fight they took over forcing a decisive
game 3 making a big difference equal
does go down mystic with the first kill
Luca still charging down the river that
double-kill now for mystic GE on the run
but against map turning with that flames
bitter but again a trip will kill now
for mystic s is shut down on the mystic
so in the end an ace for W Eve bought
there go the Nexus turrets and the GE
Tigers if they win this one they're not
gonna do it perfectly because W E is
forcing a game three I mean we could see
W II take this game it's it's now down
to that best of one sure enough and I
mean going into this match it can't be
understated if the de GE Tigers lose
this game this is undoubtedly the
biggest upset in League of Legends
history after grabbing an early lead
world elite never looked back and
completely destroyed the Tigers in what
could only be described at the time as
the greatest upset league had ever seen
things are not going well for GE Tigers
a double kill for mystic brave are they
zone a double kill now for Kuro though
and it is a bloody battle that GE Tigers
looks like they'll barely
a spirit and she has survived the
world's bass team is beaten by China
what I can't
what an incredible result and this
tournament has just been chock-full of
surprises of these upsets and that's it
the best of three the first time that we
have seen the GE Tigers lose a best-of
series w/e comes in here with their new
players no synergy no experience and
takes out an undefeated Korean team
absolutely incredible on the back of big
shake ups to North America's longest
standing roster a runner-up moment comes
from cloud 9 at the 2015 na regional
qualifier
you see c9 barely avoided relegation
during the 2015 summer split and had one
last shot at Worlds the dawn as strange
as it sounds to call cloud nine a
cinderella story they could go on a
miracle run to secure their third
consecutive appearance of world they
reverse swept gravity to come back from
the o2 that gravity put them in to go 3
to 2 versus gravity in the first call it
game of the North American summer split
cloud nine are moving on to take on
impulse they reverse swept team impulse
to give up the base they give up the
game
the series cloud9 get through a first
sweep and they're gonna face Team Liquid
c9 came together when it mattered most
and managed to topple Team Liquid
earning their third consecutive spot at
Worlds kill them off incarnation zones
amount that's gonna be the Nexus World
Championship MacLeod
and lemonnation almost can't believe it
from seventh place in the regular season
tow boys taking the top spot on our list
is a run so story so impressive it's
become one of the most iconic underdog
stories in all of eSports not just
League of Legends Taipei assassins
entered the 2012 World Championship as a
complete Dark Horse and were staring
down three of the best teams in the
entire tournament they took out a
surging najin sword in a - OH sweep and
bounced back after a tough game one to
defeat one of the tournament favorites
moscowfive
to earn themselves a spot in the finals
right on the turret goes down Terry gets
caught out he can he went off with a
crescendo stopping them from using the
abilities diamond price goes down the
inhibitor is open the double kill comes
out fast on five looking very grim right
now taipei assassins but to take down
the last Nexus 10 and they will drop
Moscow five for the League of Legends
championship playoffs taipei assassin -
the first team to make it to the world
finals but it was there where they faced
their final boss the korean juggernauts
azubu frost
now you have to understand here azubu
frost had decimated the competition up
to this point mangling the best teams in
the world to get to this final and no
one thought a relatively unknown team
from Taiwan would be the ones to
challenge them azubu frost they lost out
on the five regional winners drawings
and they were the ones that got stuck in
the group stage and they proved that
they're one of the best crushed the
group stage beat up on solomid and then
they had that close three-game set in
the semi-finals if I had to guess the
crowd favorite here is going to be the
Taipei assassins
it's an underdog story people put tower
power rankings out before this
tournament who do you think has a chance
they were ranked tenth there
they've proven to the world that they
deserve to be there after losing a close
game won TPA proceeded to dismantle the
Korean champions in three back-to-back
games as well
[Applause]
[Applause]
type a sausage will take aim - they got
the shots but rebirth will drop
robberies are down we're trying to pull
something out here Stanley with the ball
on him he's gonna jump back off the boat
we're gonna get from time where some are
destroying what might say assassinating
azubu frost seen on the screen it is a
surrender
Plus cars everyone's gonna get go
Italian he will go down the veggies toys
the pics of the killing hands away from
that
Thanks
the Taipei assassins overcame incredible
odds and three potential tournament
winners to become League of Legends
greatest underdog story
[Applause]
well guys that's our list now if you are
still watching I have one question for
you why the video is over go to the
comments section maybe go watch a story
of I don't know live your life thanks
for watching if you want more great
content just like this be sure to hit
the subscribe button